Vitamins come in two types: lipid-soluble and water-soluble.
And the difference between them determines how the body transports and stores vitamins,...
...and gets rid of the excess.
The water solubles are vitamin C and B complex vitamins...
...that are made up of eight different types that each do something unique.
These are dissolved in the watery parts of fruits, vegetables and grains,...
...meaning their passage through the body is relatively straightforward.
Once inside the system, these foods are digested...
...and the vitamins within them are taken up directly by the bloodstream.
Because blood plasma is water-based,...
...water-soluble vitamins C and B have their transport cut out for them...
...and can move around freely within the body.
For lipid-soluble vitamins, dissolved in fat and found in foods like dairy, butter and oils,...
...this trip into the blood is a little more adventurous.
These vitamins make it through the stomach and the intestine,...
...where an acidic substance called bile flows in from the liver,...
...breaking up the fat and preparing it for absorption through the intestinal wall.
Because fat-soluble vitamins can't make use of the blood's watery nature,...
...they need something else to move them around,...
...and that comes from proteins that attach to the vitamins...
...and act like couriers, transporting fat solubles into the blood and around the body.
So, this difference between water or fat-soluble vitamins determines how they get into the blood.